nice to meet you margot robbie is a
real-life badass with all the work she's
done and risks she's faced to bring
harley quinn to life
which costume piece was brought to the
team by robbie but then
later called the worst mistake the
actress had ever made
what scene prep helped provide robbie
with a new party trick let's check it
out
bravo there was plenty of criticism
going around when margot robbie took to
the screen in skimpy
and often tattered clothing as harley
quinn
while director david ayer has defended
the choice explaining why these costumes
were used for the characters
fans were still upset feeling the
clothing over sexualized harley quinn
when robbie spoke up about the matter
she admitted that she didn't
love how much the outfits clung to her
body not only were many of these
costumes revealing and
quite tight that's all robbie had to
cover herself even when performing
intense stunts and
wild action scenes the actress did
acknowledge the fact that
every other member of the squad had much
more modest costumes than she did
so she had the added struggle of being
the only one on set in hot pants while
the others were in full combat suits
but this sequin shorts and whole filled
shirt is an incredible image and it was
actually inspired by a real-life rock
star
lead singer of the band blondie debbie
harry they didn't come to this look
easily though
margot robbie had to endure trying on
around a hundred different versions of
the costume throughout the development
process but
one day robbie saw a photo of debbie
harry and as soon as she saw the look
the actress knew that that was the style
harley quinn needed for that scene
it's an amazing style and definitely
suits the character but that doesn't
mean it was comfortable
robbie had to work through performing in
extremely tight and limiting clothing
as for the end result we think it was
totally worth the struggle
because that would be real classy robbie
was responsible for another key part
that contributed to harley quinn's look
but after the fact the actress wasn't
the biggest fan
robbie had tried working in a bunch of
different styles of shoes to find what
looked and moved best one day these
slick adidas heels caught robbie's eye
and there was no turning back
this was the shoe thanks to harley
quinn's wild style the stilettos were
the perfect match for the costume and
vibe robbie was hoping to achieve with
the character
they looked great but as far as the
experience of actually wearing them goes
the actress has called them the worst
mistakes she's ever made
robbie had to endure the tricky to work
in shoes and major action sequences
while she did look great working with
the adidas was a major hurdle and left
her far more vulnerable
to injuries while others on set did
complain about all their stunts and
action sequences
robbie wasn't shy to mention the fact
that she managed to do everything
in heels if we had to go through what
she had
we probably would have said something as
well
remember these spiky golden bangles
robbie warren suicide squad
these bracelets may have looked great
and totally suited harley but
that didn't mean robbie loved them much
like the adidas heels
the bangles caused robbie a lot of
issues and the actors hated wearing them
while shooting
the harley quinn actress was
continuously stabbing herself
accidentally with the spikes
leaving her with way more small injuries
than she could have anticipated
robbie wasn't just performing being
tough
with all the painful costume pieces she
had to work with the actress was exuding
way more toughness than we could have
imagined
look at me getting into the full harley
quinn look is an incredible
transformation
but when filming suicide squad robbie
had to endure
an intense six to seven hours of prep
time doing everything from body paint
tattoos makeup wig and costume while
it's a cool process
it wasn't fun or easy luckily it was
made a bit more manageable for the
actress and birds of prey where her prep
time was about 3 hours long
what made it all worse was the fact that
even after getting prepped
the harley quinn details continued to be
a hindrance to the actress
while shooting amid loads of action and
rain the hair and makeup made it really
difficult for robbie to perform
not to mention the fact that the makeup
process often continued throughout the
days as the actress needed to have
multiple bruises and cuts supplied with
makeup depending on which scene she was
filming
in the 2021 the suicide squad film
robbie performs a
wild 4 minute action sequence the
incredibly impressive scene
shows off just how skilled and creative
the actress is
her turn as harley quinn hasn't been an
easy process by any means but
that doesn't mean robbie hasn't brought
her a game and in this sequence
it really shows director james gunn has
even credited that particular scene as
one of his
favorite pieces he's ever filmed before
this scene that sees harley quinn dumped
in a vat of chemicals
is far from comfortable and during the
actual filming of it
robbie said it was the most unpleasant
thing she'd ever done in her entire
life while the liquid she was in wasn't
actual chemicals
it was a kind of sludgy paint that
robbie really struggled with
she at one point even found herself
choking while trying to catch her breath
underwater
not only that the liquid was getting
caught inside her eyes and affected her
ability to see
when she tried to open them everything
was masked with the treacherous liquid
whatever the result was it meant that we
got these great
filming her movies as harley quinn has
been far from a walk in the park
like many of robbie's roles she had to
perform under tough conditions
the actress has done filming surrounded
by explosions and gunshots and has said
it feels like her body's been in a war
zone as a result of the chaos and
natural reactions of that kind of threat
robbie's had to deal with intense
adrenaline boosts while performing
and even once she'd wrapped for the day
she still found herself in a bit of a
state of shock
for robbie being on set is sometimes
described as the worst place since she
also suffered migraines since she was
young on top of all this
the anxiety and stress of shooting
affected her ability to sleep restfully
resulting in an extremely intense few
months every time she performs as harley
quinn
number one no one is like me crashing
into the water in a car
is a terrifying situation in any respect
this was one of the most intense stunts
robbie had to pull off in suicide squad
before filming the dangerous stunt the
actress went through extremely grueling
and intense training with an expert free
water diver so she could safely pull off
the feet
one of the skills she learned was how to
hold her breath underwater for an
extremely long period of time
and it comes in handy fairly often
robbie now whips out the skill as a
party trick
courtesy of harley quinn her commitment
to training and embodying the character
as
fully as she can is definitely one of
the reasons she's such an impressive
actor
i got to hold my breath for five minutes
margot robbie does the majority of her
stunts as harley quinn
97 are performed by the actress in
suicide squad
the prep and training she undergoes to
perform these stunts has been grueling
six months prior to suicide squad the
training began with a hardcore fitness
regimen
doing two to three hours of full body
conditioning and toning a day
when it came to honing her skills for
the role itself robbie has done gun
lessons
boxing and gymnastics classes and for
birds of prey
a professional roller derby skater was
brought on to teach her how to skate
like a pro the actress went full force
with learning to rock out on roller
skates
when we said robbie's skills were varied
we weren't kidding
we're bad guys it's what we do
the work margot robbie has put into her
role is incredible
her dedication is no small feat and it
definitely pays off in the end
her costumes absolutely added to the
character but provided their fair share
of issue for robbie as well
would you ever rock those adidas
stilettos
you